c'est alors la merlette que tu m'envoies
que j'ai envoyé donc paris le 22 ou 46
hockey
cher petit ami elle n'avait que 14 ans
lorsqu'elles ont commencé à s'écrire
d'un océan à l'autre
c'était en 1946 juste après la seconde
guerre mondiale hélène et marion entame
une correspondance qui va durer treize
ans
paris se relève de l'occupation nazie
vit une pénurie et une période de
rationnement difficile à l'époque la
journaliste canadienne judith jasmin
avait lancé un appel aux québécois pour
qu'ils viennent en aide aux orphelins
d'après-guerre en france
[Musique]
un appel entendu à montréal par germaine
massicotte la mère d'hélène qui envoie
aussitôt des colis de nourriture de
vêtements à une jeune orpheline qui vit
avec sa grand-mère à paris c'était
marion d'eichmann quand ma mère a
accepté de parrainer une orpheline comme
ça de la guerre elle avait demandé que
ce soit une fille de mon âge parce
qu'elle voulait que je corresponds la
jaquette verte qui me va très bien
le petit boléro et adorable ainsi que la
petite cuillère de montréal je vous
envoie un bon baisers et un amical
souvenir d'une nouvelle petite amie
marion un moment émouvant pour marion
qui relie ces lettres en compagnie
d'hélène qu'elles rencontrent pour la
première fois à 85 ans quand j'ai reçu
d'abord la première lettre
l'année dernière je tombais j'ai dû
m'asseoir les larmes sont venus parce
que c'est se retrouver cette partie de
moi même qu'on oublie par exemple et
dans une une des lettres je disais qu'on
en 46 qu'on rester coucher à la maison
pratiquement toute la journée parce
qu'on avait froid et on n'avait pas
assez à manger
et ça c'est une des choses que j'ai
jamais oublier c'est à une des choses
qui me reste est vraiment prêt n'a
jamais oublié ça les lettres sont
précieusement conservés aux archives
nationales du québec hélène stevens y
avait déposé sa correspondance
l'archiviste martelé g s'y est intéressé
j'ai vérifié le nom de
marion dash man dans google et j'ai
trouvé qu'elle avait écrit un livre en
hommage à sa mère qui était morte
archives de la tuta tout a découlé et
c'est grâce à elle que les deux hommes
ont repris contact ça a été vraiment une
très grande surprise pour moi je ne
m'attendais pas à ce que ça ça aboutisse
à cette merveilleuse histoire à cette
merveilleuse rencontre
[Musique]
alors oui on va au bord du fleuve elle n
avait hâte de montrer son havre de paix
au bord du fleuve saint laurent
c'est la première fois que marion se
confie de vive voix et l'aisne car au
début de leur correspondance marion
venait de perdre sa mère durant la rafle
du vel d'hiv sont venus avec une liste
et il en réalise des schumann et venez
avec nous donc elle est partie moi je
voulais partir avec elle elle mali où
marion reste soit sage sa mère n'avait
que 39 ans et c'est dans ce livre pour
que son nom apparaisse partout que
marion racontera son histoire
c'est en lisant les livres que j'ai
réalisé et que j'ai appris pour sa maman
est là je me suis dit mais on n'en
parlait pas
elle m'a pas écrit tout ça là ça m'a
vraiment bouleversée ça l'a vraiment je
le suis dit mais j'adorerais la
rejoindre dans les correspondances
marion mentionne très peu les horreurs
de la guerre
ensemble elles ont visité le musée de
l'holocauste à montréal de droit sied à
un chouette
les chanteurs à hélène stevens a visité
le camp de concentration d'auschwitz
mais pas marion d'allemagne pour qui ce
serait trop douloureux comment j'ai été
un billet aurait pu être moi porter
l'étoile c'est un peu la petite histoire
qui raconte la grande parce que
l'histoire de marion c'est leur art du
vel d'hiv c'est toutes les épreuves que
que les gens qui subissent des guerres
vive allure
oui mais aujourd'hui fériés marion et
hélène auront eu des vies très
différentes
70 ans plus tard elles revivent leur
complicité d'adolescentes avec ce réel
bonheur de s'être retrouvés
[Musique]